hi i'm roy rasheen and i'm the director
of breeding insight and today i'm going
to be talking about building breeding
support for usda ars
horticultural crops
so breeders have a number of challenges
to get to where
they can release newer and better
varieties faster and unlike most of the
annual or major crops horticultural
crops face additional challenges
in terms of logistical challenges
they're running with a small budget a
small workforce generally it's temporary
a lot of temporary labor and by its very
nature the crops are more
labor-intensive in their management and
production
in terms of technical
challenges new tech is really hard for a
small program to adopt they don't know
where to start they're not sure if it's
the right technology to meet their needs
they have no idea if the maintenance
cost is something they can afford and
they're not really always sure how it's
going to fit into their workflow
environmentalism affects everybody and
the
droughts floods seasonal fluctuations
and climate change are affecting all
breeders globally however if you're not
breeding for an annual crop you have to
be thinking much further ahead and need
a bigger source of genetic diversity to
combat the things that are coming
because you're always breeding a couple
of years behind what's actually
happening right now
and lastly horticultural crops have a
lot of biological issues so they may
have a really complex genome
they have may have a longer life cycle a
biennial or perennial life cycle a lot
of self-incompatibility may still exist
and they may even have separate genders
and the most of the biggest problem is
really the time to maturity so
it takes you know five to six years for
a citrus plant to actually produce fruit
so you're always working behind the
clock
and when i think about breeding programs
i think about three different types and
the first type is phenotypic selection
where breeder knowledge is far more
important to the decision process than
genetics
in this case
breeding
is is done by eye and it takes a lot of
time to perfect that breeder's art
it relies on very high numbers where
you're putting out thousands of
individuals and calling down to maybe a
few thousand for advancement
and there's this is very effective it's
how most breeding has been uh
been done for you know generations and
years if you think about dogs or cats or
any other kind of species where
phenotypic breeding is happening and it
is really easy to adopt it's very easy
to get started you could do it in your
garden at home
but it takes years to really perfect
and so
in terms of some examples
citrus blueberry cranberry and again
most horticultural crops fall into this
category
the next step up is marker assisted
selection where breeders knowledge is
still being is still critical and and
central to decision making but it's
being supplemented with information from
genetics
and
this is typically done for resistance
genes or other kinds of key
digestibility disease
genes where you want to be able to
screen very early in your populations
the things that do not have the markers
that you care about for a release
variety
and it does require you having markers
that are distributed genome wine and it
does
require that you understand that the
relationship of those markers to your
genes of interest
and so when a breeder considers moving
from phenotypic selection to marker
assisted selection there are real
barriers to entry for those breeders who
want to adopt that technology and it's
the culmination of all the logistical
technical and biological challenges that
are preventing technology adoption or
program growth
and the last stage is genomic selection
where the breeder's knowledge is still
important but it's superseded by the
genetic information so the breeder
knowledge is typically used more towards
the end of the breeding program when it
comes time to
make a selection of between a couple of
different cultivars as to what would be
released
and genetics is really helping to
streamline the program much earlier in
the in the breeding cycle
and genomic selection requires both high
quality phenotypic data for the traits
of interest and genome-wide genotyping
of individuals in your population
again when a breeder decides they want
to move to more genomic selection to get
more efficiency in their program there
are new barriers to entry that pamper
that transition
and we get the question from a lot of
our phenotypic readers why do i need to
add genomics and it really comes down to
that sequencing technology is accessible
and affordable for all species
and breeders have a lot of information
they have to collect assimilate and act
upon in very short windows of time with
fixed constraints
and breeders don't get to see if they
were right until it's too late to change
course
so by supplementing the breeder's eye
with genomic data and analytics and
prediction models we can free breeders
from a lot of this grunt work
and release reduce the uncertainty while
still staying within the program's
constraints
really want to make sure that the
breeders get to do more breeding
so we need to understand what a breeder
needs to make good progress they need to
manage their breeding program have their
data all in one place
they need to have tools that help them
collect data in the field
they need to manage and store that trait
data and they need to manage samples
that they're collecting whether it's
leaf tissue for dna extraction or it's
post-harvest analysis
they want to have access to what's in
the usda germplasm banks is that's the
primary place they're going to go for
new native traits and pre-breeding
activities
they need to be able to store and
retrieve genetic data
and bring that data along with the trade
data together to produce these genomic
analyses to help make improved decisions
and to also do better reporting
so at breeding insight we are here
piloting with six usda specialty
breeding programs and we start by
getting to know the programs and
listening to them about what their wants
and needs are
we provide resources by making
connections to
getting them genotypic platforms to
providing vendors to help them uh keep
the costs down we help them manage that
data
we also help them manage and accumulate
phenotypic data of higher quality and we
provide
reading support and consultation so
we're here as their partner in their
technology adoption journey
and we also help deliver software and
we're working in a public sphere so we
are creating open source software and
we're not looking to reinvent the wheel
so we look at what's available
and then we decide what functionality is
not already available that needs to be
there for our breeder specific use cases
and then we create software to meet
those those gaps
and in order to make uh an in a holistic
system
we need to have back to seamless back to
back end communication so that data is
moving from one software component to
another without the need for manual
transfer
and we need to have an overlay of a ui
that looks really breeder friendly and
meets the needs of each individual
breeding program
so one thing we found by talking to our
breeders is that no matter what you're
breeding for whether it be
fish or
um
alfalfa that your fo breeders are
following a 12-month breeding cycle and
that means that things that are
happening in one part of the cycle are
not happening in another
so to help us understand that we broke
it down into the workflows that are
actually happening in time so breeders
are having to manage stocks and
pedigrees perform crosses and design and
manage trials at the beginning of the
cycle
they're having to capture phenotypes
whether it's on paper or audio or some
mobile device
they're having to evaluate and genotypes
and evaluate their phenotypes
all so that they can finally make
decisions and selections whether it's
genomic selection or marker assisted
selection and then finally their annual
reports so breeding insight is really
dedicated to creating a digital
ecosystem where breeders can manage
their workflows in time with the cycle
and flux of their own program in the
calendar year
so our initial platform
is starts with breedbase which has
general functionality and we believe is
going to be fairly species agnostic
we're partnering with fieldbook from the
phenoapps suite to do mobile phenotyping
on
uh android devices in the field
we're using gigwa for our backend
genomic
data
database storage
and we're going we're in underway
to connect with green global to allow
breeders to be able to seamlessly look
at what's in the green global databases
and to request uh materials and the way
we're connecting these disparate systems
is by using the breeding api or the
or what we call brappy and that's a
communication standard that allows
different software to communicate
information back and forth between each
other without the need for a human to
manually transfer data on excel files
so right now breeding insight is in the
pilot phase and what that means is that
it's an ars
initiative aimed at
ars breeders of specialty crop animals
and natural resources and we fall under
the national program direction of tim
reinhart
and right now we're only breeding for
three out of about 50 specialty crops
about two out of the 15 specialty
animals and only one of the natural
resource or of the 30 that are available
but we're hoping as we grow and expand
this program out that our vision for one
breeding insight really is to support
all the
specialty crops plus the national
germplasm repositories for pre-breeding
activities
all the specialty animals and any
natural resources that are available now
or will become breeding crops as as we
change the the scope of what we're
breeding for
and in order to do that we will still be
relying on the breeding insight core
that's at cornell
but ars is will be making a commitment
to distribute breeding insight
coordinators area-wide nationally so
that they can be
more more hands-on with the breeders as
they adopt technologies
and one of the ways ars is doing this is
by creating an ars readiness program
called bi on-ramp and it's for
non-specialty crop and animal breeders
that wouldn't qualify for breeding
insight because they're not specialty
crops
and it's also for ars specialty crop and
animal breeders that want or need a more
extended transition into bi and this one
to two year commitment really allows
them to get their trade ontology set up
to migrate data from paper to digital to
really start organizing their program
and making some decisions about how they
want to expand and build capacity in
their program
and really the story is is that together
bi and bi on ram can build better tools
for all public breeders because a lot of
the same things are needed both in ars
breeding programs as well as in public
breeding programs and because our
species are going to be diversified
we're going to be able to build the most
species agnostic system when we work
together
and with that i would like to thank my
whole entire team they do the work i'm
just the one getting to do the talking
our ars collaborators are fantastic
along with our oversight from our
national program leaders at the bottom
and our scientific advisory board we do
have a github all of our software is
available freely you're welcome to
go there and download
anything that's of interest to you thank
you